Last week, I went out in the woods in Oregon with this bird expert, Noah Strycker, looking at birds. Every day he goes out for at least an hour-- often, it's a lot more-- on trails around his house that he and his parents cleared back when he was a kid. And I'd never been birding. I had no idea how much of bird watching you're actually just listening for the birds. When we'd set out in the morning, it was still foggy.
上周，我和鸟类专家诺亚·斯特里克（Noah Strycker）一起去俄勒冈州的树林里观察鸟类。他每天至少会花一小时，甚至更多时间，走在他小时候和父母一起开辟的小路上。我以前从未观鸟。我根本不知道观鸟竟然大部分时间是在听鸟叫。当我们早上出发时，林子里还有些雾气。
Already, I can hear some birds calling now. So there's a spotted towhee, [IMITATING BIRD CALL], calling just behind me. That [IMITATING BIRD CALL] was a California quail waking up. Did you hear that little [IMITATING BIRD CALL]? [BIRD CALL] That was the sound of a Steller's jay imitating a red-tailed hawk.
我已经能听到一些鸟在叫了。那是一只斑点拖喜雀，[模仿鸟叫]，就在我身后鸣叫。那声[模仿鸟叫]是加州鹌鹑醒了。你听见那声短促的[模仿鸟叫]了吗？[鸟叫声]那是斯特勒蓝鸦在模仿红尾鵟的叫声。
Wait, you know the birds well enough you can tell when a bird is imitating another bird badly?
等等，你对鸟类这么了解，甚至能听出鸟模仿另一种鸟模仿得不好？
Yeah, it's not a real red-tailed hawk. Steller's jays are just kind of bullies, in general, and they imitate red tailed hawks, as far as I can tell, just to terrorize other little birds in the forest.
是啊，那不是真正的红尾鵟。斯特勒蓝鸦总的来说就是些恶霸，据我观察，它们模仿红尾鵟就是为了恐吓森林里其他小鸟。
Does it work?
这招管用吗？
I don't know, honestly.
老实说，我不知道。
What's weird about this is if Noah can tell that it's not a red-tailed hawk, and he's not even a bird, can't other birds tell? If they can, why would the Steller jay keep doing it? To answer that question, Noah tells me about how, a couple of years ago, he bought this powerful microphone, a parabolic microphone, that could capture bird sounds from a great distance.
奇怪的是，如果诺亚能听出那不是红尾鵟，而且他甚至不是一只鸟，难道其他鸟听不出来吗？如果它们听得出来，为什么斯特勒蓝鸦还要一直这么做？为了回答这个问题，诺亚告诉我，几年前他买了一个强大的麦克风，一个抛物面麦克风，可以捕捉到远处的鸟鸣。
The first bird I ever aimed it at was a Steller's jay sitting up on a branch.
我第一次用它对准的目标，是一只停在树枝上的斯特勒蓝鸦。
So he turned on his recorder, put on headphones, and waited for it to make some noise.
于是他打开录音机，戴上耳机，等待它发出声音。
And I realized it was sitting up there with its beak closed, singing a very quiet whisper song to itself that only itself could have possibly heard because it was so quiet. That just blew my mind. I have never listened to birds the same sense. So I think they do make noises just for their own sake a lot of the time.
我意识到它当时闭着喙，正在对自己唱一首极轻的低语之歌，因为声音太小了，可能只有它自己能听到。这让我大开眼界。从那以后，我听鸟叫的感觉就完全不同了。所以我认为它们很多时候发出声音只是为了自己。
Going out birding with Noah is going out with somebody who is insanely knowledgeable about birds. He's written five books about their behavior, toured the world, seeing 6,000 of the nearly 11,000 existing bird species in just one year, in 2015. So he knows a lot. But he's also still completely excited about birds. Can't get enough.
和诺亚一起去观鸟，就像和一位对鸟类了解得疯狂的人在一起。他写过五本关于鸟类行为的书，走遍了世界，仅在2015年一年内，就看到了近11,000种现有鸟类中的6,000种。所以他知道的很多。但他对鸟类依然充满热情。总是看不够。
He told me this story. He goes to Antarctica for months studying penguins, and sometimes he gives tours to visitors of the penguin colonies. At first he says they love it.
他给我讲了这样一个故事。他去南极洲研究企鹅好几个月，有时会带游客参观企鹅聚居地。他说一开始游客们非常喜欢。
They go into their colony, they see the baby penguins, which are super cute. And then, like, day five or so, people get up in the morning and they're like, where are we going to go today? And you say, we're going to a penguin colony. And there's this look that I've learned to recognize. It's like, I've just been to eight other penguin colonies in the past four days. How is this one going to be any different? But for me, I have never felt that look in my whole life. I have never got penguined out.
他们走进聚居地，看到超级可爱的企鹅宝宝。但大约到了第五天左右，人们早上起来就会问，今天我们要去哪儿？你说，我们要去一个企鹅聚居地。然后就会出现一种我学会辨认的眼神。那眼神好像在说，我过去四天已经去过八个企鹅聚居地了。这一个和别的有什么不同吗？但对我来说，我这辈子从没那种感觉。我从未对企鹅感到厌倦。
He happily goes back to the same colony, or the same woods around his house, every single day. Noah says this endless interest in birds began in sort of typical ways. In fifth grade, he first noticed birds for real when his teacher suction-cupped a bird feeder to the classroom window, and he could stare at the birds through the glass just inches away.
他乐此不疲地每天回到同一个聚居地，或者他家周围同样的树林里。诺亚说，这种对鸟类无止境的兴趣始于一些典型的方式。五年级时，老师在教室窗户上吸了一个喂鸟器，他可以隔着玻璃近距离盯着鸟看，只有几英寸远。
He started reading the field guide, looking for birds on his own, joined a local birding club. Everybody else in the club, by the way, was in their 60s, 70s, and 80s. He was like 12. The one kid. This energetic, birdy Doogie Howser. In person, Noah actually does have kind of a Neil Patrick Harris vibe.
他开始阅读野外指南，独自寻找鸟类，并加入了当地的观鸟俱乐部。顺便说一下，俱乐部里其他人都在60、70和80岁左右。而他当时大约12岁。唯一的一个孩子。一个精力充沛、热爱鸟类的天才神童。本人看起来，诺亚确实有点尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯（Neil Patrick Harris）的气质。
But the thing he says that changed him from that kind of leisure time birder into somebody who organized his entire life around it happened because of turkey vultures, one particular pack of them, when he was 16. And he saw this episode of a TV show called The Life of Birds, where David Attenborough goes into a Trinidadian rainforest.
但他提到，让他从那种休闲式观鸟者变成把整个人生都围绕它组织起来的人，是因为土耳其秃鹫，特别是16岁时遇到的一群秃鹫。他看了一集名为《鸟类的一生》的电视节目，大卫·爱登堡（David Attenborough）去了特立尼达的热带雨林。
And he has this smelly old piece of steak in his hand. And then he buries the steak under the leaflet, or on the forest floor in the rainforest.
他手里拿着一块发臭的旧牛排。然后他把牛排埋在热带雨林地面的落叶下。
Let me hide it.
让我把它藏起来。
And then backs off, and then they cut. And then 45 minutes later, this turkey vulture comes sailing down through the canopy of that forest and flies unerringly right to the spot where the steak is and digs it up, moves the leaves aside, and gets the meat.
然后走开，画面剪辑了一下。45分钟后，这只土耳其秃鹫从雨林树冠上方盘旋而下，准确无误地飞到了牛排所在的地方，把它挖了出来，拨开叶子，吃到了肉。
It seems almost unbelievable.
这看起来简直不可思议。
When I saw that on The Life of Birds as a high schooler, I just immediately had one thought, which was, I've got to try this at home. That is the like best bird feeding idea I've ever seen in my life.
作为一个高中生，当我在《鸟类的一生》里看到那一幕时，我立刻产生了一个念头，那就是，我一定要在家里试一试。这是我一生中见过的最棒的喂鸟创意。
It seemed incredible to him that he might be able to lure these birds that you usually see from so far away. Turkey vultures are shy, hard to get near, and he might be able to see them close up? Then he thought, if David Attenborough got one bird to show up with some old piece of steak, maybe he would improve his odds if his bait was something bigger.
对他来说，能引诱这些平时只能远距离观察的鸟似乎太不可思议了。土耳其秃鹫很害羞，很难靠近，而他竟然能近距离观察它们？然后他想，如果大卫·爱登堡用一块旧牛排就能引来一只鸟，也许如果他的诱饵大一些，成功率会更高。
Imagine how many turkey vultures I could attract with, like, a dead deer. There are so many deer here in rural Oregon on the side of the highways and freeways. I can now go out and find roadkill, bring a whole carcass home, and see how many turkey vultures we can attract. But it was kind of hard to find a roadkill, as it turned out. It took me, like, a month to track one down.
想象一下，我可以用一只死鹿吸引多少土耳其秃鹫。在俄勒冈乡村，高速公路和高速公路边上有太多的鹿了。我现在可以出去找路杀动物，带一整具尸体回家，看看能吸引多少只土耳其秃鹫。但事实证明，找路杀动物有点难。我花了一个月才找到一个。
Another way to put that last sentence, if you aren't a 16-year-old very eager to see turkey vultures up close-- it only took a month to find a deer carcass. Noah wrestled the heavy, bloated, gaseous, yellow jacket-covered, putrid-smelling deer into the trunk of his Volvo sedan.
如果要把最后那句话换一种说法，如果你不是一个极度渴望近距离观察土耳其秃鹫的16岁少年——找一具鹿尸只花了一个月。诺亚把那头沉重、肿胀、充满气体、覆盖着黄蜂、散发着恶臭的死鹿拖进了他的沃尔沃轿车后备箱。
Got home, put the deer in a wheelbarrow, wheeled it out to this very spot, where we're standing in this pasture, and dumped it.
到家后，把鹿放进独轮车，推到我们现在站的这个牧场的这个地方，把它倒了出来。
So it's, like, right here where we're standing?
所以，就是我们站的这个地方？
This is the spot I chose.
这就是我选的地方。
At this point in our bird walk, we were standing within eyeshot of the house that he grew up in, but not too close. The cow pasture's overgrown, Douglas firs and white oaks around its edges.
在观鸟行程的这一刻，我们站在离他成长的那栋房子视线可及的地方，但不太近。牛牧场长满了杂草，边缘有花旗松和白橡树。
I thought this would be a good spot because you can see it from the sky, it has multiple approach paths from the air, so they will be as attracted as possible to this deer carcass.
我觉得这里是个好地方，因为从天空可以看见它，它有多个空中接近路径，所以它们会被尽可能多地吸引到这具鹿尸上来。
It was dark, so he went to bed, no idea if this was going to work. Gets up the next morning--
天黑了，于是他去睡觉了，不知道这事能不能成。第二天早上起来——
And there were turkey vultures everywhere. They were sitting on these trees right here. There were vultures sitting on the roof of our house, like 10 of them lined up on our roof. There were vultures circling overhead. There were probably 30 or 40 turkey vultures hanging around the yard. And when I woke up and realized that this had happened, I was so happy.
到处都是土耳其秃鹫。它们就坐在这些树上。屋顶上也有秃鹫，像排队一样坐了大概10只在我们的屋顶上。头顶上还有秃鹫在盘旋。院子里大概有30到40只土耳其秃鹫。当我醒来意识到发生了什么时，我太开心了。
I rushed out here. And I had set up a little camouflage tarp next to the deer carcass. The tarp was just kind of in this wet grass. So if I come over here, I was hunkered down right about here. So if I get down, I was sitting under the tarp with a hole in it, and my camera lens sticking out.
我冲到这里。我在鹿尸旁边搭了一个小伪装帆布。帆布就在这潮湿的草地上。如果我走到这边，我当时就缩在这里。如果我蹲下，我就坐在一个有洞的帆布下，相机镜头伸出来。
He's maybe 10 feet from the deer. He waited.
他离鹿大概只有10英尺远。他等待着。
And then finally, it was like magic. The first one came down. And once one came down, they all started just piling down.
终于，就像魔法一样。第一只落了下来。一旦有一只落下来，它们就开始全都挤下来。
It wasn't like what he imagined. He thought it was going to be chaos, like a pack of lions ripping into a zebra. What unfolded was very polite.
这和他的想象不一样。他以为会是混乱场面，就像一群狮子撕扯斑马一样。但展现出来的是非常有礼貌。
They were just delicately walking around it, standing on top of it, and starting to pick at it gingerly. It wasn't a brute force kind of thing, at all, and they were very well-behaved, I thought. There was almost, like, a pecking order involved. They knew which birds were going to eat first, and they adhered to it.
它们只是优雅地在它周围走动，站在它身上，开始小心翼翼地啄食。这根本不是那种蛮力行为，而且我觉得它们表现得非常有教养。几乎有一种等级制度在里面。它们知道哪些鸟先吃，并且遵守秩序。
Oh, so it was very orderly?
哦，所以场面很有序？
It was an orderly scene of turkey vultures eating their breakfast.
那是一个土耳其秃鹫享用早餐的有秩序的场景。
Where did they start?
它们从哪里开始吃的？
I thought it was so cool. So the softest parts of the deer, that's where the turkey vultures would start sticking their heads into. I was expecting them to tear a big hole in the side and just go at it, but that's not what happened at all. They actually started by pecking the eyes out. I guess those are the softest part of the deer. So they went for the eyeballs. And then they went in and very carefully ate the gums out of the deer, like around its teeth.
我觉得太酷了。土耳其秃鹫会把头伸进鹿身上最柔软的地方开始吃。我原以为它们会把侧面撕个大洞就开始吃，但根本不是那样。它们实际上是从啄掉眼睛开始的。我猜那是鹿身上最软的部分。所以它们先去啄眼球。然后它们进去，非常小心地把鹿牙齿周围的牙龈吃了。
They had to go for the soft parts because they don't have very strong feet or beaks. Instead, a turkey vulture just kind of sticks its head up inside the body. Its head is bald and red, with no feathers.
它们必须选择软的部分，因为它们的脚或喙不够强壮。相反，土耳其秃鹫只是把头伸进尸体内部。它的头是秃的，红色的，没有羽毛。
--which is handy for sticking inside of carcasses and not getting your feathers all messed up.
——这对于伸进尸体内部而不弄脏羽毛很方便。
The turkey vultures next start eating around the wound on the deer's shoulder, from where it got hit on the highway. Took turns eating around there until they got a big enough opening to get access to the chest and guts and everything else. Noah would go off in the mornings and do tennis camp and other kid stuff, then come back to his tarp for hours and hours.
土耳其秃鹫接下来开始吃鹿肩膀上的伤口，也就是它在公路上被撞的地方。轮流在那儿吃，直到它们弄开一个足够大的口子，进入胸腔、内脏和其他一切。诺亚早上会去网球训练营做些小孩子的事，然后回来在帆布里待上好几个小时。
I don't know how many hours I spent out here that week, but it was full afternoons, pretty much every day, all week long. So I got to see the whole process. At the beginning, the deer carcass was relatively fresh, and then gradually, it was stripped away. And by day five or day six, they were starting to disassemble the skeleton that was pretty much picked clean.
我不知道那一周我在外面待了多少小时，但基本上一整周每天都有整个下午。所以我看到了整个过程。起初，鹿尸相对新鲜，然后逐渐被剥离。到了第五天或第六天，它们开始拆解几乎被清理干净的骨架。
It was like being drawn into another world that exists in this world, that we are very seldom a part of. Being so close to these birds that don't normally allow us to get that close to them was like passing through some kind of force field or something, and emerging on their side of the divide, and feeling that.
那感觉就像被带入了存在于这个世界中的另一个世界，我们很少参与其中。如此近距离地接触这些通常不允许我们靠近的鸟类，就像穿过某种力场，出现在了界限的另一边，感受到了那种氛围。
Yeah. And their world is not the same as ours?
是的。它们的世界和我们的不一样？
No. And it has existed for much longer than ours has. I mean, humanity is not that old. Turkey vultures have been around for quite a lot longer than we have.
不。而且它存在的时间比我们要长得多。我是说，人类没那么古老。土耳其秃鹫存在的时间比我们久得多。
Man, when you stare into the eyeball of a turkey vulture and it blinks its third eyelid that birds have, that is just unsettling. They are strange, strange animals. They just have this weird, very reptilian vibe.
天哪，当你盯着一只土耳其秃鹫的眼球看，它眨动鸟类特有的第三层眼睑时，那种感觉真是让人不安。它们是非常奇怪的动物。它们有一种怪异、非常像爬行动物的氛围。
Before this, of course, he'd seen lots of birds, but it was like checking them off a list. He saw this one and that one that he'd read about in the field guide. He'd never just stared at one group of birds for so long and watched how they related to each other or what they did.
在此之前，当然，他见过很多鸟，但这就像是在清单上勾掉名字。他看到了他在野外指南里读到过的那一只和这一只。他从来没有长时间盯着一群鸟看，观察它们如何相互关联或它们在做什么。
Turkey vultures are what I would call my spark bird. For a birder, a spark bird is the one you see, usually in some kind of unexpected situation, that grabs you in a way that you haven't been grabbed before by birds, and turns you on to a wavelength that you haven't been turned on to before, in the bird world.
土耳其秃鹫是我所说的“火花鸟”。对于观鸟者来说，火花鸟是指你在某种意想不到的情况下看到的鸟，它以一种你从未被鸟类触动过的方式触动了你，把你带到了鸟类世界中一个你以前从未到达过的波长上。
Like people would talk about, what's your spark bird?
就像人们会谈论，你的火花鸟是什么？
Birders, when we get together and go out on field trips, yes, we love to say, oh yeah, what was your spark bird? Oh, that's a cool one. What was your spark bird? And you ask just about any birder out there what their spark bird is, and they'll probably have an answer for you. For me, that week watching these vultures, being in their world just gripped me. It changed my life.
观鸟者聚在一起外出考察时，是的，我们喜欢问，噢，你是哪种鸟带你入门的？噢，那很酷。你的火花鸟是什么？你问任何一个观鸟者他们的火花鸟是什么，他们大概都有答案。对我来说，那一周观察这些秃鹫，进入它们的世界，深深吸引了我。它改变了我的人生。
That week in the pasture by his house has basically turned into his entire life, thanks to the spark birds. None of us here at our program had ever heard the phrase "spark bird" before we talked to Noah. And we thought, there must be other situations where a bird arrives and changes everything. And we went looking for stories like that. We found a bunch, a whole flock of them, in all kinds of settings.
在那儿牧场边待的那一周，基本上塑造了他的一生，这都要归功于那些火花鸟。我们节目组没人听说过“火花鸟”这个词，直到我们采访诺亚。我们想，肯定还有其他情况，一只鸟出现并改变了一切。于是我们去寻找这样的故事。我们找到了一堆，一大群，在各种各样的环境下。
This weekend, when families are coming from far and wide to gather together around a bird, this seemed like the perfect time to bring those stories to you. From WBZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这个周末，当各地的家庭聚集在一起围坐在一只鸟周围时，这似乎是讲述这些故事的最佳时机。来自芝加哥WBZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Don't Chicken Out. So one thing about the birds in this show, the spark birds, is that they don't know how consequential they are. Know what I mean? They're just going about their day, picking up worms and seeds, unaware of the lives they're transforming. I'm fairly sure that that's true for the bird in this first story, though we were unable to confirm that independently with the bird.
第一幕，别当缩头乌龟。关于这个节目里的鸟，也就是火花鸟，有一点是它们不知道自己有多重要。明白吗？它们只是过着自己的日子，捡捡蚯蚓和种子，不知道自己正在改变着人们的生活。我很确定第一个故事里的那只鸟也是这样，尽管我们无法独立向那只鸟证实这一点。
One of the people in the story is Carmen Milito. Back when she was 13, in 1960, growing up on Coney Island in New York, one day she met this boy on the beach. Even today when she talks about him, the words she uses are "gorgeous," "beautiful."
故事中的一个人是卡门·米利托（Carmen Milito）。回到1960年她13岁的时候，在纽约康尼岛长大，有一天她在海滩上遇到了这个男孩。即使是今天当她谈起他时，她用的词也是“华丽”、“漂亮”。
He had just the cutest face that I've ever seen-- dimples. He just swooned me.
他有着我见过最可爱的脸——酒窝。他简直让我神魂颠倒。
He swooned her. That's how they did it back in the '60s. Girls were constantly swooning back then, over the Beatles, and Elvis, and whatnot. Anyway, she and the guy talked for 10 or 15 minutes. He strolls off.
他让她神魂颠倒。这就是60年代他们表达爱意的方式。那时候女孩们总是很容易神魂颠倒，为了披头士、猫王之类的。总之，她和那个男孩聊了10或15分钟。他走开了。
Three years later, she's at a social club in some random neighborhood, far from Coney Island. There's music playing, people dancing, and the boy walks in. Fate. He's wearing a leather jacket, slicked back hair, as teenagers did back then. Carmen points him out to her friend.
三年后，她在某个随机街区的社交俱乐部，离康尼岛很远。音乐响着，人们跳着舞，那个男孩走了进来。缘分。他穿着皮夹克，头发梳向脑后，像那时候的青少年一样。卡门指给朋友看。
And she looks over, and she goes, oh, my god, he's gorgeous.
她看过去，然后说，噢，天哪，他太帅了。
Carmen goes up to him. The guy buys her a drink. They talk for a long time. He asks her out. She's 16. His name is Bobby. She's excited. But she is too ashamed of the apartment where she lives with her mom to have him pick her up there. It was run down, she said, under the elevated train tracks. So she has him pick her up at her sister's place. Her mom is furious about this.
卡门走到他面前。那个男孩给她买了杯饮料。他们聊了很久。他约她出去。她16岁了。他的名字叫鲍比。她很兴奋。但她对自己和妈妈住的公寓感到羞愧，不敢让他到那儿接她。她说，那里破旧不堪，就在高架铁轨下面。所以她让他去她姐姐家接她。她妈妈对此非常愤怒。
She was-- you're not proud of what we have here? I work my ass off all my life, and you're embarrassed?
她当时说——你不为我们拥有的东西感到自豪吗？我这辈子工作得半死不活，你感到尴尬？
Carmen tries to tell her that she just wanted to make a good first impression. Says, don't worry, she's going to have him come to the house when he picks her up for the second date.
卡门试图告诉她，她只是想留下一个好的第一印象。她说，别担心，第二次约会他来接她时，会让他来家里。
So that day was a Saturday. And I told my mom that he's coming again to pick me up. And she put this little face on-- so what do you want me to do? Put up the flags? So she said, well, tell me about this boy. What's going on with him? So I said, well, he's an Italian guy. He lives in Bensonhurst.
那一天是星期六。我告诉妈妈他又要来接我了。她露出了那种表情——那么你想让我做什么？挂上旗帜吗？所以她说，好吧，跟我说说这个男孩。他怎么样？我说，好吧，他是个意大利小伙子。他住在本森赫斯特。
I said, he happens to be Sicilian. And she stopped. She said, no. And I said, what do you mean, no? I mean, you are not going out with any Sicilian boys. My mom is from Naples. So she had married my dad who was Sicilian, and he turned out to be a real deadbeat of a man. He deserted her when she was pregnant to me, for the babysitter, actually.
我说，他碰巧是西西里人。她停住了。她说，不。我说，你什么意思，不？我的意思是，你不准和任何西西里男孩出去。我妈妈来自那不勒斯。她嫁给了我爸爸，那个西西里人，结果他是个彻头彻尾的败类。在我怀着我的时候，他为了保姆抛弃了她。
Wow.
哇。
So when she heard that he was Sicilian, she thought that life was repeating itself. And the thoughts that came into her mind were like, you know, he's going to desert you. And I said, please, you're jumping the gun here. It's the second date. Don't worry. She says, I don't care. I don't-- so I said, mom, please.
所以当她听说他是西西里人时，她觉得历史在重演。她脑子里想的是，你知道，他会抛弃你的。我说，求你了，你这叫草木皆兵。这才是第二次约会。别担心。她说，我不在乎。我不想——所以我说，妈妈，求你了。
Carmen tells her, just go out and do the shopping while I clean the house. Her mom says, fine. She goes out. Comes back a little while later with a large cardboard box.
卡门告诉她，你去买东西吧，我来打扫房子。她妈妈说，好吧。她出去了。过了一会儿回来，提着一个大纸箱。
And in this box is a chicken.
这个盒子里是一只鸡。
The chicken, of course, is the spark bird in this story, the one that's going to change everything for Carmen.
当然，这只鸡就是这个故事里的火花鸟，那个将改变卡门一切的火花鸟。
And it's scratching that box all over the place. And I looked at it and I said, what is that? And she goes, it's a chicken. And I said, what are you going to do with it? And she goes, I'm going to kill it, and then eat it. And I said, you never killed a thing in your life. What are you talking about? You can't have this thing here now. He's going to be here any minute, and you've got a live chicken. He's going to think we're farmers or something.
它在盒子里抓挠个不停。我看着它说，那是什么？她说，这是一只鸡。我说，你打算拿它怎么办？她说，我要杀了它，然后吃了它。我说，你这辈子从没杀过生。你在说什么？你现在不能把它放在这儿。他马上就要来了，而你有一只活鸡。他会以为我们是农民之类的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I just went off. And she goes, oh, don't be ridiculous. I'll put the chicken in the bathroom. Now, the bathroom was right next to the kitchen. So you close the door and you hear everything-- everything in that bathroom.
我简直要疯了。她说，噢，别荒唐了。我会把鸡放在浴室里。浴室就在厨房旁边。你关上门，什么都能听到——浴室里的一切。
And so do you figure like, oh, this is her revenge on me? She thought I was ashamed to bring him to the house, and so here's what she's doing. She's brought a live chicken in.
所以你觉得，噢，这是她对我的报复？她以为我不敢把他带到家里来，所以她就这么做。她弄了一只活鸡进来。
Oh, yeah. I said that. I said, are you getting back at me for something? And what are you doing? She goes, oh, don't be ridiculous. She said, just go. Go. Go finish getting dressed. Don't worry. He's in the bathroom. He won't hear a sound, your precious Bobby.
噢，是的。我是这么说的。我说，你是在跟我作对吗？你在干什么？她说，噢，别荒唐了。她说，快走。走。去穿好衣服。别担心。他在浴室里。他听不到声音的，你那宝贝鲍比。
Well, as we're arguing, we hear footsteps coming down the hallway, and then there's a knock on the door. So she said, go ahead, open the door, very calmly. And it was like-- such an assurance about her. Like, she had a plan.
嗯，就在我们争论时，我们听到走廊里传来脚步声，然后有人敲门。所以她说，去吧，开门，非常冷静。她那种样子就像——很有把握。就像，她有个计划。
In walks Bobby, well-dressed, handsome as always, polite, calls Carmen's mom Mrs. Nicastro. "Call me Ida," she says, and escorts him into the kitchen. She offers him a drink. You're allowed to drink, aren't you? Bobby was 19, but it's a weird move with the boy who's going to be driving your daughter. Carmen wonders what she's up to.
鲍比走了进来，衣着讲究，一如既往地帅气，彬彬有礼，称呼卡门的妈妈为尼卡斯特罗夫人。“叫我伊达，”她说，并带他进厨房。她递给他一杯饮料。你被允许喝酒，对吧？鲍比19岁，但让一个要载你女儿出去的男孩喝酒，这招很奇怪。卡门想知道她想干什么。
So he sits down, and she gives him a drink of scotch. And she asks him questions like, where are you from? What do you do? Now, in the meantime, that chicken is scratching its way out of that box in the bathroom. And he was so kind. Never said a word. He heard it. You could see it on his face, because he'd look around like, where's this sound coming from? Oh, my god, I just wanted to die.
于是他坐下来，她给了他一杯苏格兰威士忌。她问他一些问题，比如，你是哪里人？你是做什么的？与此同时，那只鸡正在浴室里抓挠着想从盒子里出来。他当时很有礼貌。一句话也没说。他听到了。你看他脸上的表情就能看出来，因为他会环顾四周，好像在想，这声音从哪儿来的？噢，天哪，我当时真想找个地洞钻进去。
And every time the chicken would scratch at the box, I would [CLEARS THROAT], cough, or I would say, you know, we've got to go. We've got to go. And my mom would say, just a minute. She had this way of saying "just a minute." Just a minute, hold your horses. Bobby, come on, finish your drink. How about another one?
每次鸡抓箱子，我都会[清喉咙]，咳嗽，或者我会说，你知道，我们得走了。我们得走了。而我妈妈会说，等一下。她那种说“等一下”的方式。等一下，别急。鲍比，来，喝完你的饮料。再来一杯怎么样？
OK, just a word right now about Carmen's mom Ida and what she's doing here. Ida has been described to me as kind of scrappy, and sharp-witted, and willful, somebody who had to figure out how to make her way in the world. And if she wanted to convince you to do something, apparently, she was very hard to resist.
好吧，现在说几句关于卡门的妈妈伊达以及她在这里做的事情。伊达在别人描述中，是个有点好胜、机智、固执的人，一个必须自己想办法在世界上闯出名堂的人。如果她想说服你做某事，显然，你很难抵挡。
In the summer, she would pick up extra money as a barker on Coney Island, urging passersby to come in and buy tickets for the wax museum. She had worked low-paying factory jobs all her life, on her feet all day, starting when she was 13, when her parents pulled her out of school to go to work and make money for the family. When Carmen's dad her for the babysitter, she lost all of her friends, her family turned its back on her, and she had to fend for herself, learn to survive.
夏天，她会在康尼岛当拉客人员，通过赚取额外收入，敦促过路人买票参观蜡像馆。她一生都在干低薪工厂工作，整天站着，从13岁开始，当时她父母让她辍学去赚钱养家。当卡门的父亲为了保姆抛弃她时，她失去了所有的朋友，家人们也背弃了她，她不得不独自谋生，学会生存。
And she was a very sensitive woman. She would wear her heart on her sleeve.
她是个非常敏感的女人。她会把心事写在脸上。
Very protective of Carmen, who was the baby of the family. Oh, but this boy in her kitchen?
非常保护卡门，那个家里的宝贝。噢，但厨房里的这个男孩？
She just saw Sicilian. That's all she saw.
她只看到了西西里人。她只看到这个。
Right.
对。
And she had a plan. She was like a little-- crazy as a fox. And then she said, wait a minute, I have to ask Bobby something. Tell me, Bobby, did you ever kill a chicken? And he looks around, he looks at me, and he goes, why, is there a problem? And she said no, no problem. She said, I just want to know if you ever killed a chicken. And so he looks at her and says-- he lied. He said, sure, yeah. I killed a chicken.
她有个计划。她简直像只——像狐狸一样狡猾。然后她说，等一下，我得问鲍比一件事。告诉我，鲍比，你杀过鸡吗？他环顾四周，看着我，然后说，怎么，有问题吗？她说不，没问题。她说，我只是想知道你有没有杀过鸡。于是他看着她说——他撒谎了。他说，当然，有的。我杀过鸡。
She goes, oh, I knew you did. And she goes, Bobby, listen. Do me a favor, honey. I have this chicken in the bathroom. Would you do me a big favor? Can you kill it before you leave? Well, you could have heard a pin drop in that room. It was silent. And I said, mom what-- no. And I'm screaming. I'm carrying on. No, you can't do this. He's all dressed. She goes, don't worry about it. I'll get him an apron. And then she grabs the chicken, she puts the apron on him, she goes in the bathroom, and she puts the box with the chicken on the table. And she says, here.
她说，噢，我就知道你杀过。她说，鲍比，听着。帮我个忙，亲爱的。我浴室里有这只鸡。你能帮我个大忙吗？你能在走之前杀了它吗？嗯，你简直能听到房间里针掉落的声音。一片寂静。我说，妈妈，什么——不。我尖叫着。我大吵大闹。不，你不能这么做。他穿得这么帅。她说，别担心。我给他弄件围裙。然后她抓住鸡，给他穿上围裙，走进浴室，把装鸡的盒子放在桌子上。她说，给你。
So he opens the box up, and this chicken's running around the box, and he closes the flap right away. And he goes, I don't know if I can do this. And she goes, you said you could. Don't disappoint me now, Bobby. Please, you promised. And he's like, looking at me, and I'm looking at him, and all of a sudden I started to say, will he do this? And he closes the flaps, and he said, [SIGH]. God, do you have a knife?
于是他打开盒子，鸡在盒子里跑来跑去，他马上关上了盖子。他说，我不知道我能不能做到。她说，你说你能做到的。别让我失望，鲍比。求你了，你答应过的。他看着我，我看着他，突然我开始说，他会做吗？他关上盖子，说，[叹气]。天哪，你有刀吗？
OK, I'm going to spare you the details of how he killed the chicken without getting blood on his white Ban-Lon shirt, or anything else. But it was swift and surprisingly deft for somebody who had never killed a chicken in his life.
好了，我省去他如何在不让血弄脏他白色Ban-Lon衬衫或其他任何东西的情况下杀死那只鸡的细节。但这对于一个从未杀过鸡的人来说，既迅速又出人意料地熟练。
And I was, like, in shock. I couldn't move. And my mother was dancing all over the kitchen. You are a gem. I think I'm going to love you. You come back on Sunday, and I'm going to make you the best chicken cacciatore you ever ate in your life. She gives him a towel to wipe his hands. She was treating him like some god of sorts. I mean, she was, like, in heaven. And she looked at me, and she gave me this big wink and a thumbs-up sign, kind of. It's like, you have a winner here. She goes, go ahead. Go out now and have a ball. She said, you'll come back on Sunday? And he said, I think so. Yeah, I guess. And we left and did not say a word to each other.
我当时惊呆了。我动弹不得。我母亲在厨房里跳舞。你真是个宝贝。我想我会爱上你的。你星期天回来，我要给你做这辈子吃过最好的猎人炖鸡。她递给他一块毛巾擦手。她对待他就像对待某种神一样。我的意思是，她简直像在天堂。她看着我，对我挤挤眼，比了个大拇指。就像是，你找对了人。她说，去吧。现在去玩个痛快。她说，你星期天会回来吗？他说，我想会吧。是的，我想。我们离开了，彼此没说一句话。
You and he didn't say a word to each other about--
你和他没说一句话关于——
Not a word. A word was not spoken. We sat in the car. And I just stared out. He stared out. And we started to laugh. And that was the end of the conversation. Never again was it mentioned.
没说一个字。一个字都没提。我们坐在车里。我就盯着外面。他盯着外面。然后我们开始笑。谈话就这样结束了。再也没提过这件事。
What happened was, we continued to go out and see each other. And 56 years later, we're still married. This is the man of my dreams. We're still married after 56 years.
后来我们继续约会。56年后，我们仍然结婚。这是我梦寐以求的男人。56年后我们仍然在一起。
Carmen says asking him to kill the chicken, it was a test.
卡门说让他杀鸡，这是一个考验。
Any other guy would have said, you're crazy, lady. I'm not going to kill this chicken. She believed that that would have been his response, but he just, I guess, was in love with me, and just said, I've got to do it for her, you know?
任何其他人都会说，你疯了吧，女士。我才不会杀这只鸡。她相信这会是他的反应，但他只是，我想，因为爱我，就说，我得为她做这件事，你知道吗？
Oh that's what the test proved? It proved his feelings about you?
噢，这就是考验证明的东西？它证明了他对你的感情？
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, totally. He killed something for me. She knew that if he wasn't the guy for me, he would have never done this.
是的。噢，是的。噢，完全证明了。他为我杀了东西。她知道如果他不是我的真命天子，他永远不会这么做。
You know, I never really looked at it that way. I looked at it like my manhood was being questioned.
你知道，我从来没有那样想过。我以为它是在质疑我的男子气概。
This, of course, is the man in question, Bobby. Though Bobby was a nickname. As he got older, he switched to using his given name, Sebastian.
这当然就是故事里的那位男人，鲍比。虽然鲍比是个昵称。随着年龄增长，他改用自己的本名，塞巴斯蒂安。
You know, like, did I have the stones to kill a chicken? I was 19. And see, when you're 19, you're insecure. And she sort of threw a test, which I thought, maybe, was some primitive ritual that came from the village that-- they were from Naples, from Sorrento. And maybe that's how they did it in Sorrento.
你知道，就像是，我有没有种去杀一只鸡？我当时19岁。看，当你19岁时，你是不自信的。她似乎抛出了一个考验，我想，也许是某种来自村庄的原始仪式——他们来自那不勒斯，来自索伦托。也许这就是他们在索伦托的做法。
Oh, my god.
噢，我的上帝。
They devised a test for--
他们设计了一个考验——
Please don't call it primitive. Don't say primitive. I don't want to get letters from people from Sorrento.
请别叫它原始。别说原始。我不想收到来自索伦托人的信。
Anyway, I didn't want to be embarrassed in front of-- I don't want Carmen to think of me as not being manly enough to do something like that. But at that point, I don't think I did it out of love.
总之，我不想在……面前出丑。我不想让卡门认为我没有足够的男子气概去完成那样的事情。但在那个时候，我不认为我是出于爱才做的。
I mean, it's funny, because I think they both took it-- or at least her mom took it as a sign of, oh, you really like her. And it's funny to think that she got it wrong.
我的意思是，这很有趣，因为我认为他们两人都——或者至少她妈妈把它当作一种信号，噢，你真的很喜欢她。觉得她理解错了，这很有趣。
Well, I did like her. I mean, I was crazy about her. But I didn't say, I'm going to do this for Carmen.
好吧，我的确喜欢她。我的意思是，我为她疯狂。但我并没有说，我要为了卡门做这件事。
It was just their second date, after all.
毕竟，那只是他们的第二次约会。
Would have done that for any girl's mom?
你会为任何女孩的妈妈做那种事吗？
You know, Ira, I can't think of any other girl's mom would ever ask me to do that. She was very wily, and a good person. I mean, I loved her. I loved her dearly.
你知道，艾拉，我想不出任何其他女孩的妈妈会要求我做那样的事。她非常狡黠，也是个好人。我的意思是，我爱她。我深爱着她。
When Carmen was 16 and her mom pulled off this plan, she was horrified. But now, she's two decades older than her mom was that day in 1963 when this happened, and she has kids and grandkids of her own. And she sees her mom's actions that day very differently.
当卡门16岁，她妈妈策划了这个计划时，她感到惊恐。但现在，她比1963年发生这件事那天她妈妈当时的年龄还要大二十岁，她也有了自己的孩子和孙辈。她现在以完全不同的方式看待她妈妈当天的行为。
I adore her for doing that. I could cry, wanting that night back. The bravery of her to do something like that. I can't imagine her doing anything else, actually. She wasn't a talker. She wouldn't have sat down with him and said, listen, I want you to respect my-- she wasn't going to say anything like that. She was going to give him a test.
我崇拜她那样做。我甚至想哭，真想回到那个夜晚。她敢那样做，真是勇敢。事实上，我无法想象她做别的事。她不是个多话的人。她不会坐在他面前说，听着，我要你尊重我的——她不会说那种话。她会给他一个考验。
And in that test, even though she was wrong about whether Sebastian had killed that bird out of love for Carmen, if you look at her mom's bigger conclusion, that he was going to be a reliable man for Carmen, that he was going to stick around and be there for Carmen, a half century later, it's probably safe to say she got that part right.
而在这个考验中，尽管她关于塞巴斯蒂安是否出于爱卡门而杀鸟的判断是错的，但如果你看看她妈妈更宏大的结论，即他会成为卡门的可靠伴侣，他会留下来陪伴卡门，半个世纪后，大概可以肯定地说，她那部分是对的。
Coming up, the rarest bird species in the world-- so rare that only one family in Massachusetts has ever spotted them, or until right now, even knows about them. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，世界上最稀有的鸟类——稀有到只有马萨诸塞州的一个家庭见过它们，或者说直到现在才知道它们。稍后回来，芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "Spark Bird." During this week, when the tradition is to gather together at a table around a bird, we have stories of spark birds, the birds that get it all started for somebody, that make you see things differently. And if you're just tuning in, we began our program today with Noah Strycker, who's the author of The Thing With Feathers and other books on bird behavior, somebody who's spark bird was the turkey vulture.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“火花鸟”。在这一周，当传统是全家围坐在桌子旁享用禽类时，我们带来了火花鸟的故事，那些让一切开始的鸟，那些让你以不同视角观察事物的鸟。如果你刚调过来，我们今天节目的开头介绍了诺亚·斯特里克，他是《羽毛的秘密》及其他关于鸟类行为书籍的作者，他的火花鸟是土耳其秃鹫。
And one of our producers, Chloee Weiner, and I spent hours tromping around the woods with him in Creswell, Oregon, which was hours of actually doing the thing that today's show is about-- learning to see things differently through birds. And I just want to play you a little more of this, because so much of what Noah told us along the way was new to me and Chloee. For instance, Noah was telling us how this summer, late one night, he was home, and he heard this bird sound he'd never heard before.
我们的制作人之一克洛伊·温纳（Chloee Weiner）和我花了好几个小时在俄勒冈州克雷斯韦尔的树林里跟着他跋涉，那实际上是我们今天节目主题的实践——通过鸟类学会以不同的方式观察事物。我只是想再给你们放一点内容，因为诺亚沿途告诉我们的很多东西对我克洛伊来说都是新的。比如，诺亚告诉我们今年夏天的一天深夜，他在家时，听到了一种他以前从未听过的鸟鸣声。
I don't even know. It was like [IMITATING BIRD CALL]. And I came running out here with my flashlight because it was dark, because I had no idea what it was, and tracked it down. And it was a fledgling screech owl sitting on a branch.
我甚至不知道。它听起来像[模仿鸟叫]。因为天黑，我没想通那是什么，于是带着手电筒跑了出来，循声找到了它。那是一只坐在树枝上的幼年鸣角鸮。
And it's just like-- it hadn't learned yet how to make the proper screech owl noise?
它就像是——它还没学会如何发出正确的鸣角鸮叫声？
Yeah. Birds babble, just like human babies do. Scientists will call it subsong, and have these other technical terms for it, but it's just birds learning how to sound like birds.
是的。鸟类会咿呀学语，就像人类婴儿一样。科学家称之为亚鸣，还有其他专业术语，但那只是鸟类在学习如何听起来像鸟。
Birds babble like human babies do. I didn't know. I honestly never think about the fact that I live in the middle of a whole world of birds. I don't notice them. I don't hear them singing. But of course, Noah cannot stop himself from hearing them, and instantly recognizing that that's a Pacific grand, that's a chestnut-backed chickadee, or whatever. And he doesn't just hear the bird sounds when he's walking around outside.
鸟类像人类婴儿一样咿呀学语。我不知道。我老实说，从没想过我生活在整个鸟类的世界里。我没注意它们。我没听到它们在鸣叫。但当然，诺亚无法阻止自己去听它们的声音，并能瞬间识别出那是太平洋鹪鹩，那是栗背山雀，诸如此类。而且他在外面走路时，听到的不仅仅是鸟叫声。
Becoming a birder ruins Hollywood movies for you forever, because whatever bird sounds are in the background, in the soundtrack, whether they're just natural or whether they've dubbed them in, even, they're never the birds that would be in the place that the movie is set, at the season that it's set in. And it drives me nuts. I mean, how hard would it be to put the proper bird sounds in there?
成为一名观鸟者会让你永远无法再正常欣赏好莱坞电影了，因为无论背景音乐里有什么鸟叫声，无论是自然的还是后期配音的，它们从来都不是电影设置的季节、设置的地点里应该出现的鸟。这让我抓狂。我的意思是，放进正确的鸟叫声有多难？
Like, what's a movie that this happened to you in?
比如，哪部电影里发生过这种情况？
Well, just yesterday, I saw the movie Spencer, the new Lady Di movie. They had red-winged blackbirds in the background. This is supposed to be, what, in like, Europe, in the UK somewhere. Red-winged blackbirds don't live in Europe. That's a whole continent away from where they would actually live. They had Steller's jays in the background, and all kinds of North American species. So obviously, this movie was filmed by North Americans who were dubbing in North American birds into a completely wrong background.
好吧，就在昨天，我看了电影《斯宾塞》，那部关于戴安娜王妃的新电影。背景里有红翅黑鹂。这应该是，什么，在欧洲，英国某个地方。红翅黑鹂不住在欧洲。离它们真正生活的地方隔着整个大洲。它们背景里有斯特勒蓝鸦，还有各种北美的品种。所以显然，这部电影是由北美人拍摄的，他们把北美的鸟类配到了一个完全错误的背景中。
And just the lengths to which they go to get all of the historical details and period pieces accurate, the shape of the headlight, that no one is ever going to know, honestly, when you watch the movie. And yet the bird sounds are all over the map. And there are so many birders out there, like me, who know what they're listening to. That's not unusual.
他们为了确保所有的历史细节和时代背景准确，比如前灯的形状，花费了那么多精力，老实说，看电影时没人会注意到。然而鸟叫声却完全不对。而且有那么多像我这样的观鸟者，知道自己在听什么。这并不稀奇。
This, I guess, would be the downside of having a birder open your eyes to something about the world that most people don't notice. It wouldn't be hard to fix this, Noah says. There are archives with most bird sounds. Movie sound editors, Noah would love to hook you up. Drop him a line, he says. And of course, the problem is, the world doesn't care about birders. Hollywood knows that they'll continue to show up with their factually inaccurate movies and stream their error-ridden television shows, because where else are they going to go when they need to watch something that's indoors and not wild, alive, and feathered?
我想这就是让观鸟者为你打开世界的一扇窗的坏处，大多数人根本注意不到。诺亚说，修复这个不难。有大部分鸟鸣声的档案。电影音效编辑们，诺亚很乐意帮你们。他说，发信息给他。当然，问题在于，世界并不在乎观鸟者。好莱坞知道他们会继续放映那些事实不准确的电影，播放那些漏洞百出的电视剧，因为当人们需要看些室内的、不是野生的、活的、长着羽毛的东西时，还能去哪儿呢？
Act 2, A Scrub is a Bird that Can't Get No Love from Me. So we now turn to a spark bird that started a political fight, a fight that has lasted for a very long time, concerning one state's official state bird. Bim Adewunmi tells the tale.
第二幕，灌丛鸦是不会被我爱的鸟。现在我们转到一个火花鸟，它引发了一场政治争端，一场持续了很长时间的争端，关于一个州的州鸟。比姆·阿德武米（Bim Adewunmi）来讲述这个故事。
The thing about an official state bird is that it just really doesn't matter. I say that with no intended disrespect to birders across the nation. Some of my best friends are birders. But think about it. When was the last time you sat down and truly considered the scissor-tailed flycatcher, who is the avian embodiment of the state of Oklahoma? Exactly. It's absurd.
关于正式州鸟的事是，它真的无关紧要。我对全国的观鸟者毫无不敬之意，这么说。我的一些最好的朋友就是观鸟者。但想想看。上一次你坐下来，真正考虑剪尾王霸鹟是什么时候？它可是俄克拉荷马州的鸟类化身。没错。这太荒谬了。
A state bird has nothing to do with the state's GDP, for example. It doesn't tell us how happy the children are. It makes no one's life materially better or worse. And yet in Florida, the debate about which flying animal deserves the title of official state bird has been ongoing for more than two decades. The state bird means nothing. But somehow, in Florida, it's come to mean a hell of a lot.
例如，州鸟与该州的GDP无关。它并不能告诉我们孩子们有多快乐。它没让任何人的生活变得更好或更坏。然而在佛罗里达州，关于哪种飞行生物配得上州鸟头衔的辩论已经持续了二十多年。州鸟什么也代表不了。但不知何故，在佛罗里达，它变得非常重要。
Florida was actually one of the first states to designate a state bird, back in 1927. It was probably a simple choice. The northern mockingbird is a good bird, as birds go. It likes to sing. It has an incredible talent for mimicry. And with its gray coloring, it's cute. Here's the thing, though. The northern mockingbird is the official bird of another four states besides Florida. It's actually the third most popular state bird, behind the northern cardinal and the western meadowlark.
佛罗里达实际上是首批指定州鸟的州之一，早在1927年。那可能是一个简单的选择。嘲鸫是众多鸟类中不错的一种。它喜欢唱歌。它有不可思议的模仿天赋。而且它的灰色外表很可爱。不过重点是。嘲鸫除了佛罗里达州外，还是另外四个州的官方鸟类。实际上它是第三受欢迎的州鸟，仅次于北美红雀和西部草地鹨。
After 72 years, some people have had enough of this spread-thin state bird. Enter the spark bird of this story, the scrub jay. The Florida scrub jay is the only bird on the planet that is found only in Florida. It's a sturdy-looking bird with a dull blue head and wings. It's unclear exactly why the late Republican Rep. Howard Futch was such a champion for the scrub jay, but in 1999, he co-sponsored a bill for it to become the state bird.
72年后，有些人对这种普及程度过高的州鸟受够了。故事里的火花鸟登场了，灌丛鸦。佛罗里达灌丛鸦是地球上唯一仅见于佛罗里达的鸟类。它看起来很结实，头部和翅膀是暗蓝色的。不清楚已故共和党众议员霍华德·福奇（Howard Futch）为什么如此支持灌丛鸦，但在1999年，他联合发起了将其定为州鸟的法案。
Maybe it was the fact that Futch represented Brevard County, which used to have the highest number of scrub jays in the state. But I think he just liked the bird. As he puts it, "It's got good family values, it's kind, and it's a bird that likes people."
也许是因为福奇代表布里瓦德县，该县曾拥有州内数量最多的灌丛鸦。但我认为他就是喜欢这种鸟。正如他所说，“它有良好的家庭价值观，很和善，而且是一种喜欢人类的鸟。”
Scrub jays do something called cooperative breeding, which means that each nest has an adult pair, but it also has helpers, usually the older siblings of the newest jay babies, who help feed the young and defend territory. Very different, in Futch's opinion, from the mockingbird. "The mockingbird, a lot of people love that sucker," he said, "but it's pretty mean."
灌丛鸦做一种被称为合作繁殖的事情，这意味着每个巢都有成年配对，但也有帮手，通常是最新雏鸟的年长兄弟姐妹，它们帮助喂养幼鸟并保卫领地。福奇认为，这与嘲鸫截然不同。“嘲鸫，很多人喜欢那个混蛋，”他说，“但它非常刻薄。”
There's nothing human beings cannot make about themselves, even birds. And the fight over the Florida state bird very quickly became loaded with familiar political tropes. On the side of the status quo, the side of the incumbent mockingbird, was one of Florida's most famous seniors, Marion Hammer. Hammer is a long-time lobbyist with the National Rifle Association, and the architect of Florida's "stand your ground" law. And she is no fan of the Florida scrub jay.
人类没有什么事是不能扯上自己的，鸟类也不例外。而关于佛罗里达州鸟的争斗很快就充满了熟悉的政治陈词滥调。站在现状一边，支持现任嘲鸫一方的，是佛罗里达最著名的资深人士之一，玛丽恩·哈默（Marion Hammer）。哈默是全国步枪协会的长期游说者，也是佛罗里达“就地防卫法”的架构师。她一点也不喜欢佛罗里达灌丛鸦。
In her committee testimony, Hammer dismissed the bird as a thieving scrounger in the strongest possible terms. "They eat the eggs of other birds," she said. "That's robbery and murder." And in response to the scrub jay's alleged friendliness, exemplified by the way it eats out of humans' hands, she had a rebuttal. "Begging for food isn't sweet. It's lazy, and it's a welfare mentality." The response from the other side was just as harsh. Democrat Rep. Mark Pafford called the mockingbird "an obnoxious, plagiarizing, and promiscuous bully."
在委员会证词中，哈默用最强烈的措辞斥责这种鸟为小偷和寄生者。“它们吃别的鸟的蛋，”她说，“那是抢劫和谋杀。”对于灌丛鸦据称的友好，体现在它从人类手中吃东西的方式上，她有反驳：“乞讨食物并不可爱。那是懒惰，是一种福利心态。”另一方的反应同样严厉。民主党众议员马克·帕福德（Mark Pafford）称嘲鸫为“一种令人厌恶的、剽窃的、混乱的恶霸”。
State Rep. Futch and the scrub jay have the Audubon Society on their side, and they also had a chunk of Florida citizens-- schoolchildren. Thousands of them signed a petition in support of the scrub jay. Hammer had a hunch about who was behind these passionate schoolchildren. She suggested they had been influenced by environmentalists trying to secure extra protections for the scrub jay. It's adults hiding behind impressionable children, she said. If they get it on the endangered list, you can kiss your property rights goodbye.
州众议员福奇和灌丛鸦有奥杜邦协会的支持，他们还有一部分佛罗里达公民——小学生。数千名小学生签署了支持灌丛鸦的请愿书。哈默预感到是谁在这些充满激情的小学生背后推波助澜。她暗示他们受到了试图为灌丛鸦争取额外保护的环保人士的影响。她说，这是成年人躲在易受影响的孩子身后。如果它们被列入濒危物种名单，你的财产权就完了。
This had begun as an argument about something that means nothing, but now it had become an argument about the biggest things. It would have been neater if the camps were strictly Republican versus Democrat, but bird choice and party affiliation didn't always align. The choice of state bird became a proxy referendum about what traits Floridians should find admirable.
这本是一个关于毫无意义的东西的争论，但现在它已经变成了关于大事物的争论。如果阵营严格按共和党对民主党划分会更整洁，但鸟类选择和党派归属并不总是一致的。州鸟的选择成了关于佛罗里达人应该推崇什么特质的代理全民公决。
Depending on which side you were on, the mockingbird was either a stand-in for rugged, talented individualism, or it was a raucous bully. And the scrub jay, seen through one lens as nurturing family values, and sweet enough to pal around with humans, somehow also became the poster child for a reliance on big government and its handouts.
取决于你站在哪一边，嘲鸫要么是坚韧、有天赋的个人主义者的代表，要么是一个喧闹的恶霸。而灌丛鸦，通过一个视角看是培养家庭价值观，足够甜蜜去结交人类，不知何故也成了依赖大政府及其施舍的代言鸟。
Here's where it is now. In the 2022 legislative session, there will be three new bills, from Democrats and Republicans alike, to change the state bird. By the way, there are other candidates besides the scrub jay. Every previous bill has died in committee. It always dies in committee. But hope dies last.
目前情况是这样。在2022年的立法会议上，将会有三项新法案，来自民主党和共和党，旨在改变州鸟。顺便说一下，除了灌丛鸦还有其他候选者。之前的每项法案都在委员会中夭折了。它总是夭折在委员会。但希望永存。
As recently as last month, Hammer was defending the mockingbird and making the scrub jays sound like phantoms from a '90s crime bill, calling them "evil little birds that rob the nests of other birds and eat their eggs and kill their babies. One might call that street gang behavior in the avian community."
就在上个月，哈默还在为嘲鸫辩护，并把灌丛鸦形容为90年代犯罪法案中的幻影，称它们为“邪恶的小鸟，抢劫其他鸟的巢穴，吃它们的蛋，杀死它们的幼崽。有人可能会称那为鸟类社区里的街头帮派行为。”
I'm very familiar with irrational and hyperbolic debates about regional fauna. In my own home country, the UK, we are not above turning benign animal behavior into weird politicking. There has long been a PR battle waged between the indigenous and endangered red squirrel, by some accounts, a noble and scrappy creature, and the gray squirrel, a larger, invasive American interloper who has ideas well above its station.
我非常熟悉关于地区动物的非理性和夸张的辩论。在我自己的国家，英国，我们也免不了将温和的动物行为变成奇怪的政治作秀。在本土且濒危的红松鼠之间，有人说它是高贵而勇敢的生物；与灰松鼠，一个体型较大、入侵美国的闯入者，它自视甚高，两者之间长期进行着PR战争。
It has brought forth every type of nativist narrative you can imagine. In a debate in the House of Lords in 2006, Lady Saltoun of Abernethy likened the red squirrel to "quiet, well-behaved people who do not make a nuisance or an exhibition of themselves, or commit crimes, and so do not get themselves into the papers in the vulgar way gray squirrels do."
它带来了你能想象到的每一种本土主义叙事。在2006年上议院的一次辩论中，阿伯内西的盐敦夫人将红松鼠比作“安静、行为端正的人，他们不会制造麻烦或出风头，也不会犯罪，所以不会像灰松鼠那样以低俗的方式登上报纸。”
When I was at University, I swear I read tabloid stories that basically compared gray squirrels to American GIs during and after World War II-- overfed, oversexed, and over here. Since 2008, Prince Charles has been the patron of the Red Squirrel Survival Trust. In 2017, the Prince backed a government plan to sterilize gray squirrels, using Nutella as bait.
我在大学时，发誓读到过小报故事，基本上把灰松鼠比作二战期间及之后的美国大兵——过度喂养、过度性化，还在这里。自2008年以来，查尔斯王子一直是红松鼠生存信托基金的赞助人。2017年，王子支持了一项用能多益作为诱饵对灰松鼠进行绝育的政府计划。
That's a step beyond what Floridians are doing. They've yet to weaponize any spreads or condiments in their fight to choose a state bird-- a state bird whose anointment will make no one's life worse or better.
那比佛罗里达人做的更进一步。他们还没有在选择州鸟的斗争中武器化任何涂抹酱或调味品——一种任命之后不会让任何人的生活变坏或变好的州鸟。
(HOST) IRA GLASS. Bim Adewunmi. She fears no birds and respects only one-- the crow.
(主持人) 艾拉·格拉斯。比姆·阿德武米。她不畏惧鸟类，只尊重一种——乌鸦。
Act 3, We Need to Talk About Birdly. OK, I just want to say a word about what I find interesting about this next story. I think every couple, there are the things that you share and talk about with each other, and then other things you don't share so much. But each couple has to kind of invent or discover the territory of stuff that they have in common, and where they meet up. And the more stuff in that territory, probably, the better because the more chances you have to connect, and feel close, and all that.
第三幕，我们得谈谈鸟鸟（Birdly）。好吧，我只是想说一句关于下一个故事我觉得有趣的地方。我想每对夫妻都有你们分享和谈论的事情，也有其他不那么分享的事情。但每对夫妻都必须通过某种方式发明或发现他们共同的领域，以及他们相遇的地方。而在那个领域里的东西越多，可能就越好，因为你们有更多的机会去联系，去感到亲近，诸如此类。
The couple in this story, they had their stuff. They were even raising kids together, which is obviously a huge thing like that. But as the kids got older, the couple invented this whole other original common ground for themselves. Also, there's birds. Sean Cole explains.
这个故事里的夫妻，他们有他们的共同点。他们甚至一起抚养孩子，这显然是一件大事。但随着孩子长大，这对夫妻为自己发明了另一个全新的共同点。而且还有鸟。肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）来解释。
Before I get into what this story is about, I just want to say that the couple in question, Peter and his wife Maddy, are normal people.
在我进入这个故事的主题之前，我只想说故事中的这对夫妇，彼得（Peter）和他的妻子玛迪（Maddy），是正常人。
You must be Maddy.
你一定是玛迪。
I am.
我是。
Hi.
你好。
Nice to meet you, Sean.
很高兴见到你，肖恩。
Great to meet you. How are you?
很高兴见到你。你好吗？
Welcome. Come in.
欢迎。进来吧。
Thank you. Their house in Northampton, Massachusetts is so normal, it's beige. Four bedrooms upstairs, one for each kid. Peter and Maddy crammed themselves into the attic for a long time. They're a blended family. Peter came to the marriage with two sons. Maddy has a son and a daughter. All of them are grown, doing well. Now, it's just the parents at home. Maddy works as a lawyer. Recently won a big case through the Innocence Project.
谢谢。他们在马萨诸塞州北安普顿的房子非常正常，米色的。楼上有四个卧室，每个孩子一间。彼得和玛迪在阁楼挤了很长时间。他们是一个重组家庭。彼得带着两个儿子结婚。玛迪有一个儿子和一个女儿。他们都长大了，发展得很好。现在，家里只有父母了。玛迪是一名律师。最近通过“无罪计划”赢得了一场大案。
So I do trial work and I do appellate work.
所以我做审判工作和上诉工作。
Peter is a professional musician, has toured Europe playing Bach arrangements on a special guitar he designed.
彼得是一名专业音乐家，曾在欧洲巡演，用他设计的一种特制吉他演奏巴赫改编曲。
Like, I've been an artist all my life. I think about it, I'm really grateful for that.
就像，我一生都是艺术家。想到这点，我真的很感激。
And for more than 10 years now, a sizable number of their conversations with each other concern a family of imaginary birds with whom they live. Six birds who do not exist, and yet each have names and distinct personalities, successes and failures. Most of them have corresponding stuffed animals associated with them.
而且十多年来，他们彼此之间相当大一部分对话都围绕着一个他们住在一起的虚构鸟类家庭展开。六只不存在的鸟，但它们都有名字和鲜明的个性，有成功也有失败。大多数鸟都有对应的毛绒玩具。
Peter and Maddy might spend more time talking about these birds than about anything in reality. The birds' lives resemble those of grade-school children. They attend Bird Academy, ride there on the bird bus, and they're kind of little menaces, always accidentally spilling things on themselves and throwing parties at the house when Peter and Maddy are away. Yet they somehow also medaled in the Olympics and recorded a Grammy award-winning record. Here's Maddy.
彼得和玛迪花在谈论这些鸟上的时间可能比谈论现实中任何事情的时间都多。这些鸟的生活就像小学生的。它们去鸟类学院上学，坐鸟巴士去，它们有点像小破坏狂，总是意外地把东西洒在自己身上，在彼得和玛迪不在家时开派对。然而不知何故，它们也在奥运会上拿过奖牌，并录制了一张格莱美获奖唱片。玛迪来说说。
It's odd. I mean, I know it's odd. Upon reflection, because it's like this Byzantine storyline now-- it's every day. And it's, like, woven all through the day. And for example, if I was doing something at work, like a difficult meeting with a client at a jail, or something, then afterwards, when I would call Peter to say, I'm on my way home, or whatever, then he would say, how were the birds? Like how did they do? And then I would say, terrible, usually. Usually, the birds do terribly. So the birds had a tantrum in the car with my colleague. The birds were rude to the investigator. Like, that's sort of how it arises a lot, is asking how the birds managed what we were managing, sort of.
很奇怪。我的意思是，我知道这很奇怪。回想起来，因为这就像是一个拜占庭式的故事情节了——每天都在发生。而且它贯穿了一整天。例如，如果我在工作中做了什么事，比如在监狱里和客户开了一场艰难的会议之类，事后，当我打电话给彼得说，我正在回家路上之类的，他就会问，鸟儿们怎么样？它们表现如何？然后我会说，糟糕，通常都是。通常鸟儿们表现得很糟糕。所以鸟儿们在车里跟我同事发脾气。鸟儿们对调查员很不礼貌。所以这经常会出现，问问鸟儿们是如何应对我们正在处理的事情的。
Like, when Peter went up to Maine to visit his son Chester, who just fixed up an old boat that he was sailing and living on, which Peter is really proud of him for having accomplished.
比如，当彼得去缅因州探望他的儿子切斯特（Chester）时，切斯特刚修好了一艘旧船，正在上面航行和生活，彼得为他的成就感到非常自豪。
And of course, when I'm on the phone with Maddy, calling her from up there, it's like, well, the birds didn't really like the boat. The boat is really small. They thought it was going to be like the boat on the TV show Succession, the nice yacht.
当然，当我在那里给玛迪打电话时，就像，嗯，鸟儿们不太喜欢那艘船。那船太小了。它们以为那会像电视节目《继承之战》里的那艘船，那种漂亮的游艇。
Which, by the way, is not how Peter felt about the boat. The views and opinions of the birds do not necessarily reflect those of Peter and Maddy. Sometimes, they do, but it's not that simple. It's more like they're this messy Greek chorus that always has to be accounted for and factored into almost every experience. And it's like a very elaborate running joke. They like seeing what each other is going to come up with next, poke fun at each other via the birds.
顺便说一下，彼得对这艘船的感觉并不是这样。鸟儿们的观点和意见并不一定反映彼得和玛迪的观点。有时会，但没那么简单。它们更像是一个杂乱的希腊合唱团，总是必须被考虑到，并被纳入几乎每一个体验中。这就像一个非常精心的长久笑话。他们喜欢看对方接下来会想出什么，通过鸟儿们开对方的玩笑。
Push and pull and go, no the birds don't do that. The birds do this. What are you talking about? The birds hate skating. And it's like, wait, what about Birds on Ice?
推推搡搡说，不，鸟儿们不那样做。鸟儿们这样做。你在说什么？鸟儿们讨厌滑冰。就像，等等，那冰上鸟类表演怎么办？
The birds have an annual event called Birdfest.
鸟儿们有一个年度活动叫“鸟类节”。
Which is always canceled at the last minute.
总是最后一分钟被取消。
At the last minute, it will turn out they didn't really have a permit, they hadn't really spoken to Beyonce's manager.
在最后一分钟，结果发现它们其实并没有许可证，它们根本没和碧昂丝的经纪人谈过。
The throwing out ideas and coming to a consensus is a lot of how they built the bird world. For instance, the birds are really into milkshakes. Their birdmobiles are outfitted with special shake machines. But they filed a lawsuit against Shake Shack after one of them got his head feathers caught in a ceiling fan.
抛出想法并达成共识是他们构建鸟类世界的主要方式。例如，鸟儿们非常喜欢奶昔。它们的鸟车配备了特殊的奶昔机。但它们对Shake Shack提起了一场诉讼，因为其中一只的头羽被吊扇卷进去了。
Which is really a shame, because the birds love Shake Shack.
这真是太遗憾了，因为鸟儿们爱Shake Shack。
But they're not banned from Shake Shack.
但它们没被Shake Shack禁止进入。
They're not banned, but it must have soured them on the whole Shake Shack experience.
它们没被禁止，但那肯定让它们对整个Shake Shack的体验感到酸楚。
I don't think so, honey. They got a ton of money, and they still can get shakes there.
我不这么认为，亲爱的。它们拿到了一大笔钱，而且它们依然能在那里买到奶昔。
OK. Yeah.
好吧。是的。
It's important to say, too, this is the first time Peter and Maddy have ever talked about the birds in front of anyone. Other than their kids-- and Peter's therapist once or twice, in passing-- they've never mentioned the birds to a single soul until now. It's just too out there, they told me, and too hard to explain, which means this is also the first time they've had to answer any questions about the birds.
也必须说，这是彼得和玛迪第一次在任何人面前谈论这些鸟。除了他们的孩子——还有彼得的治疗师偶尔提到过一两次——直到现在，他们从未向任何灵魂提到过这些鸟。他们告诉我说，这太出格了，也太难解释了，这意味着这也是他们第一次不得不回答关于鸟儿们的问题。
They've never examined any of this, even in private. So when I asked them something like why they do it, or what they get out of it, they really had to puzzle together those answers in real time, as I sat with them.
他们甚至从未私下审视过这一切。所以当我问他们为什么这样做，或者从中得到什么时，他们真的必须在我坐着和他们聊天时，实时把这些答案拼凑起来。
I'm not trying to sell it. You know what I'm saying? I'm just reporting it, that it's happening here.
我不是在兜售它。你知道我在说什么吗？我只是在报道它，它确实在这里发生了。
And the whole thing with the birds, it isn't just frivolous. It's actually been helpful in the family in some ways, and hurtful too, which I'll get to. But just to say how it began, the birds first entered their lives about a dozen years ago, when Maddy's daughter-- Peter's stepdaughter-- Eva, bought Maddy a little stuffed toy monster. Technically, it was something called an UglyDoll, but to Maddy, it looked like a bird. Eva was only about 12 years old at the time.
关于鸟儿们的整个事情，不仅仅是轻浮。在家庭方面它实际上是有帮助的，也有伤害的，我稍后会讲到。但只说它如何开始，鸟儿们在大约十二年前第一次进入他们的生活，当时玛迪的女儿——彼得的继女——伊娃（Eva），给玛迪买了一个小毛绒怪物玩具。从技术上讲，它是某种叫UglyDoll的东西，但对玛迪来说，它看起来像一只鸟。伊娃当时才12岁左右。
And I do think it was the first thing that she had ever bought for me. So it was a very sweet gift. And I just loved it so much. And then I gave it this silly name, Birdly.
我觉得这是她第一次给我买的东西。所以这是一份非常甜蜜的礼物。我非常喜欢它。然后我给了它这个傻乎乎的名字，鸟鸟（Birdly）。
So Birdly was the spark bird, the bird that sparked the, capital B, Birds. Maddy started bringing Birdly everywhere. Birdly rode in the car with her. She took him on vacation. Peter would idly toss him to the other side of the bed, and Maddy would be like, hey, careful.
所以鸟鸟就是火花鸟，那只火花鸟点燃了那个，大写字母B的，鸟类（Birds）。玛迪开始带着鸟鸟到处走。鸟鸟和她一起骑车。她带它去度假。彼得会漫不经心地把它扔到床的另一边，玛迪就会说，嘿，小心点。
And this hadn't dawned on Maddy until we talked about it, but this was around the same time that her custody arrangement with her ex-husband was changing. Used to be, the kids would never be away from her for more than three days at a time. But then they switched to one week on, one week off.
玛迪在我们聊起这个之前还没意识到，但这大约是她和前夫的监护权协议正在改变的时候。以前，孩子们离开她的时间绝不会超过三天。但后来他们改为一周在一起，一周分开。
And in the beginning, the week that I did not have them felt like an eternity. It was a challenge. I think it was fair, and I think it was the right thing to do, but that was a period that I was missing my children. So I think that may have been why I got super attached, even, to the bird that she gave me.
起初，我没有他们的那一周感觉像永恒。那是一个挑战。我认为这很公平，而且我认为这是正确的事情，但那段时间我在想念我的孩子。所以我认为这可能就是为什么我甚至对她给我的那只鸟超级依恋的原因。
And very quickly, Birdly grew a personality of his own-- adventurous, irresponsible, Machiavellian. He'd take out credit cards in Peter and Maddy's names, neglect to file his taxes for five years. But Maddy would dote on him nonetheless.
很快，鸟鸟就长出了自己的个性——冒险、不负责任、马基雅维利式。它会用彼得和玛迪的名字申请信用卡，五年不报税。但玛迪依然对它宠爱有加。
At first, I found Birdly really annoying. She just got so exaggerated about how precious he was. And I would just be like, OK, all right, you know like, please. And then somewhere, I crossed some line and moved over into, well, he didn't do a thing to help do the dishes, or something, you know? Like, participating in it. And then she'd be like, what? He had to work on his presentation for school tomorrow. And we would talk about it--
起初，我觉得鸟鸟真的很烦人。她夸大了它有多珍贵。我只会说，好吧，行了，你知道，求你了。然后不知何故，我越过了一条线，进入了，嗯，它洗碗一点忙都没帮，之类的，你知道吗？就像，参与其中。然后她会说，什么？它明天还要为学校准备演讲。我们会谈论它——
The psychologist and marriage expert John Gottman talks about how couples are always sending each other these little requests for attention-- subtle, like, wow, would you look at that sunset? Sometimes, the other partner just shrugs. But in some couples, the more contented ones, the partner responds enthusiastically, like, oh, wow, yeah! It's beautiful. I think the birds are requests like that.
心理学家和婚姻专家约翰·戈特曼（John Gottman）谈到夫妻总是如何向对方发送这些微小的注意力请求——细微的，比如，哇，你看那个日落吗？有时，另一方只是耸耸肩。但在某些夫妻中，那些更满足的，伴侣会热情回应，比如，噢，哇，是的！它很美。我认为鸟儿们就像那样的请求。
Sometimes, the birds will even swoop in and help them communicate something that's difficult to express. Like, this one time-- he's fine now. But Peter was deathly ill. He had a bacterial infection in his spine. And they were driving back from a doctor's appointment where they'd gotten some bad news. The mood in the car was dire. And after saying nothing for a long time, Peter goes, oh, we have to stop at the mall. The birds want to go to the mall.
有时，鸟儿们甚至会俯冲下来，帮助他们沟通一些难以表达的事情。比如，有一次——他现在没事了。但彼得病得很重。他的脊椎有细菌感染。他们正从医生的预约那里开车回来，得到了一些坏消息。车里的气氛很压抑。在很长一段时间没说话后，彼得说，噢，我们得在商场停一下。鸟儿们想去商场。
I mean, what else are you going to say, right? Yeah, I remember it as the best way for me to say something like, don't worry about me. I mean, you can't tell her not to worry. But you can talk about the birds. What about the birds? They want to go to the mall.
我的意思是，还能说什么呢，对吧？是的，我记得这是我表达像，别担心我，最好的方式。我的意思是，你不能告诉她别担心。但你可以谈论鸟儿们。鸟儿们怎么了？它们想去商场。
And then here's the way in which the birds have not been so great for the family. Again, there are four kids. And they each had somewhat different responses to Bird World. The oldest, Torsten, thought it was kind of funny, and he left for college anyway, not long after it started. Hank was indifferent, accepted it as some kind of code that his parents used to communicate. Chester, the very youngest of the four, thought it was annoying and not funny. And then there was Eva who, again, gave Maddy, her mother, the doll in the first place, and who was the most aggrieved.
然后这就是鸟儿们对这个家庭来说不太好的方式。再说一遍，有四个孩子。他们每个人对鸟类世界的反应有些不同。老大托尔斯滕（Torsten）觉得它很有趣，而且他开始不久就去上大学了。汉克（Hank）无动于衷，接受它为父母用来交流的某种代码。四个孩子中最小的切斯特（Chester）觉得它很烦人，一点也不好笑。然后是伊娃（Eva），她又一次，买了这个娃娃给玛迪，她的母亲，而且是最觉得委屈的那个。
Oh I was definitely jealous.
噢，我绝对是嫉妒了。
This is Eva. She's 25 now.
这是伊娃。她现在25岁了。
I was jealous of Birdly. I don't know if I felt forgotten, but I was definitely jealous.
我嫉妒鸟鸟。我不知道我是不是觉得被遗忘了，但我绝对是嫉妒了。
Now, as the youngest of Maddy's two kids, Eva was used to being the baby, doted on, showered with affection. And suddenly, she had to bear witness to this overwhelming, overweening geyser of praise and attention her mom gave Birdly and the other birds.
现在，作为玛迪两个孩子中最小的一个，伊娃习惯了当那个被宠爱、被赞美和关注淹没的宝贝。突然间，她不得不亲眼目睹母亲给鸟鸟和其他鸟儿那种压倒性的、过分的赞美和关注。
The theme that bothers me the most is, if you say something about your life, and then the birds have their own thing about their life. So it would be like, if you got an A, the birds either got an A++, or they got an F-. But mom is still, somehow, more interested in their F- than she is in your A, which I'm sure wasn't true, but that's just how it felt at the time. That's really when the intense dislike of Birdly began to build.
最困扰我的主题是，如果你说了一些关于你生活的事情，然后鸟儿们有了关于它们自己生活的事情。所以就像是，如果你得了A，鸟儿们要么得了A++，要么得了F-。但妈妈不知何故，对它们的F-比对你的A更感兴趣，我知道这肯定不是真的，但当时感觉就是那样。那才是对鸟鸟产生强烈厌恶开始建立的时候。
And build, and build, and build, until sometimes, it exploded.
然后建立，建立，建立，直到有时，它爆炸了。
I don't think I was clear enough that I wasn't kidding when I am saying that the birds thing bothers me. I'm not playing along with the bird universe, where nobody likes the birds, and they're sticky and annoying, and they're failing out of classes, and their teachers are reporting them. I really, really don't like it. Like, I couldn't say that, or I wasn't saying it right. So I think that it was like it always felt like it was playing along, until I had a tantrum. And I would scream at her that they're not real, which I think did hurt her feelings.
我想我不够清楚地表明我不是在开玩笑，当我说是鸟儿们困扰我时。我不参与鸟类世界，没有人喜欢那些鸟，它们黏糊糊的又烦人，它们在课堂上不及格，老师在举报它们。我真的，真的不喜欢它。就像，我没法说出来，或者我没说对。所以我认为这总感觉像是在陪着演戏，直到我发脾气。我会对着她尖叫说它们不是真的，我想这确实伤害了她的感情。
And looking back on it now, Eva says her mother was giving her an appropriate amount of attention, affection, praise, all of that. But back then, she really felt like she was in competition for it. And after all, the birds didn't deserve it because, you know, them not existing and all. Anyway, for the first couple of years, it was just Birdly, just the one bird. And then, this one fateful day, Eva took action.
现在回想起来，伊娃说她母亲给予了她适量的关注、感情、赞美，所有这些。但在当时，她真的觉得自己在争夺它。而且毕竟，鸟儿们不配得到它，因为，你知道，它们不存在之类的。总之，头几年，只有鸟鸟，只有那一只鸟。然后，在这个宿命的一天，伊娃采取了行动。
I'd had enough. And I stole him, and I hid him between the box spring and the mattress of the bed that I slept on. And then I forgot that I did that. I honest to goodness forgot that I had done that.
我受够了。我偷了它，把它藏在我睡的那张床的弹簧箱和床垫之间。然后我就忘了我做过那件事。我老实说确实忘了我做过那件事。
I felt panic. I tore the house apart. I mean, I felt the panic that you feel if you have an indoor/outdoor cat and they don't come home at night. I was so disappointed in myself that I had carelessly lost him.
我感到恐慌。我把房子翻了个底朝天。我的意思是，如果你有一只室内/室外猫，它们晚上没回家，你会感到那种恐慌。我对自己粗心大意弄丢了它感到非常失望。
Which, of course, in Eva's mind, confirmed all of her fears that Maddy loved Birdly more. She got even more jealous. And then, finally, Peter went out and bought another Birdly-- exactly the same doll, same color, whole thing. But instead of telling Maddy, here, honey, I know how much you miss that doll, so I bought you another one, he claimed to have found the original Birdly, which was just more willful suspension of disbelief.
当然，在伊娃看来，这证实了她所有关于玛迪更爱鸟鸟的恐惧。她变得更加嫉妒了。然后，终于，彼得出去买了一只新的鸟鸟——完全一样的娃娃，颜色一样，整体都一样。但他没告诉玛迪，嘿，亲爱的，我知道你多想念那个娃娃，所以我买了另一个给你，他声称找到了最初的那个鸟鸟，那只是又一次对不信的刻意暂停。
Like, of course, Birdly isn't someone you can just go out and purchase at a store any old time. He's unique. A bird in a million. And that was good enough for Maddy. She felt a lot better. But then a couple of months after that, Maddy's doing a really thorough cleaning of the house, is in her daughter Eva's room, turns the mattress over-- and you can see where this is going.
就像，当然，鸟鸟不是你随便什么时间去商店就能买到的那种人。它是独一无二的。百万分之一的鸟。这对玛迪来说就足够了。她感觉好多了。但就在那之后几个月，玛迪在给房子做彻底大扫除，在女儿伊娃的房间里，翻转床垫——你可以预见接下来会发生什么。
She comes to me and she's like, look what I found. And I was like, that's-- you're right. That's Birdly, and that's because all this while his twin sister has been pretending to be him to make you feel better while he was-- he had to go out into the world.
她来到我面前，说，看我找到了什么。我当时就像，那——你是对的。那是鸟鸟，这是因为这段时间它的孪生妹妹一直假装是它来让你感觉好点，而他——他必须去外面的世界。
And his twin sister, being the newer, more pliant, cleaner one.
而它的孪生妹妹，作为那个更新、更温顺、更干净的。
Correct. Yeah, who had an amazing likeness for him. It's like out of-- what is it Twelfth Night-- or something, you know? I'm kind of proud of that, although I'm also bewildered by it. And she just loved that.
正确。是的，它和它长得太像了。这就像出自——什么东西——第十二夜之类的，你知道吗？我对此感到很骄傲，虽然我也为此感到困惑。她真的很喜欢那样。
So that is how Birdladette was born.
所以这就是鸟妹妹（Birdladette）诞生的经过。
Birdladette, Birdly's twin. And soon, all of the other birds joined the flock too. One of Peter's sons gave Maddy a doll she called Dr. Botley.
鸟妹妹，鸟鸟的孪生姐妹。很快，所有其他的鸟也加入了这个鸟群。彼得的一个儿子给了玛迪一个娃娃，她叫它波特利医生（Dr. Botley）。
He looks a little like a robot, but he's a bird and a doctor. He's received the Nobel Prize for medicine for having cured space rash.
它看起来有点像个机器人，但它是一只鸟和一名医生。它因治愈了太空疹而获得了诺贝尔医学奖。
Eva gave me the insider scoop on Dr. Botley.
伊娃给了我关于波特利医生的独家消息。
He's also missing. I think that I hid him, and I don't know where.
它也失踪了。我想是我藏了它，但我不知道藏在哪。
He's currently missing?
它现在失踪了？
He's been missing for years. But if you ask mom, she'll tell you he's on sabbatical.
它已经失踪好几年了。但如果你问妈妈，她会告诉你它在休假。
Next came Hubaletta, or Hubsie. She's an owl. Then there's Penguino, a penguin who's studying to be a birdmobile mechanic.
接下来是胡巴莱塔（Hubaletta），或胡布西（Hubsie）。它是一只猫头鹰。然后是企鹅（Penguino），一只正在学习做鸟车修理工的企鹅。
He is in the car, and we use him as, like, a lumbar pillow.
它在车里，我们把它当成腰枕用。
And finally there's Wing, who, he's not embodied. No physical incorporation whatsoever, stuffed or otherwise. So at this point, Eva's original goal, to disappear Birdly so that Maddy wouldn't pay so much attention to him, could not have backfired more badly. Her parents' conversations now involved exactly 500% more birds than there had been. And to make matters worse, her older brother Torsten, when he was home, would occasionally get into the act, egging their mother on to keep telling bird stories.
最后是翼（Wing），它没有化身。根本没有物理上的结合，没填充物或其他东西。所以这时候，伊娃最初的目标，想让鸟鸟消失以便玛迪不会那么关注它，结果事与愿违。她父母现在涉及的关于鸟儿们的对话比以前多了500%。而且更糟的是，她的哥哥托尔斯滕（Torsten），当他在家时，偶尔会参与其中，怂恿他们的母亲继续讲鸟儿们的故事。
And again, it was like there's no malice there. They thought it was just the same as any other teasing that we as a family did all the time. But I felt replaced. And there's no way that that could have been addressed, because what are you supposed to even say, after having yelled at them? I know the birds are fake. Like, I hate you. I hate you and your fake birds. They're not real. They're just stuffed animals. To then be like, but also, I do feel they're real, and you're hurting my feelings. [LAUGHS]
再说一次，这没有恶意。他们认为这和我们作为一个家庭一直在做的任何其他打趣一样。但我感到被取代了。而且这根本没法解决，因为你 yelled at 他们之后，你还能说什么呢？我知道鸟儿们是假的。就像，我恨你们。我恨你们和你们那些假鸟。它们不是真的。它们只是毛绒玩具。然后又要说，但同时，我确实觉得它们是真的，你们在伤害我的感情。[笑声]
Because they feel real.
因为它们感觉是真的。
They are real.
它们是真的。
I mean, what is real, other than what everyone around you says is real, right? I mean, if everybody around you is talking about them and they are having significant social, emotional, psychological impact on your life, I don't see what's realer than that.
我的意思是，除了周围每个人都说它是真的，什么是真的，对吧？我的意思是，如果周围每个人都在谈论它们，而且它们对你的生活产生了重大的社会、情感、心理影响，我不觉得有什么比这更真实的了。
Eva says she's still not a fan of the birds these days. But in the last couple of years, she's finally reached a little equanimity with them. A lot's changed. She's older, has a good job. Not living at home anymore has helped. Plus, she's unpacked a lot of personal stuff that made her especially hypersensitive and insecure as a teenager. She'll even ask her mom, from time to time, how the birds are doing, just as a way of connecting with her.
伊娃说她现在仍然不是这些鸟的粉丝。但在过去几年里，她终于和它们达到了一点平衡。发生了很多变化。她大了，有份好工作。不再住家里也有所帮助。此外，她解开了许多曾经让她作为青少年时尤其敏感和不安全的东西。她甚至会偶尔问她妈妈，鸟儿们最近怎么样，作为一种与她交流的方式。
She read me this text conversation she had had with Maddy a couple of days before our interview, something about the birds needing an attachment in their birdmobiles to hold the dipping sauce for their French fries.
她给我读了我们在面试前几天她和玛迪进行的这段短信对话，关于鸟儿们在它们的鸟车里需要一个附件来放薯条用的蘸酱。
I said, birds need that. There's ranch all over the bird mobile. The steering column can barely turn. It's gooey with honey mustard. And then she said, exactly. Honey mustard is the worst because it attracts fruit flies. And I said, yes, the gearshift is all sweet and soured up. Also, ranch has dairy in it. It's a total nightmare. So that was a totally normal bird conversation. Totally entertaining. Totally fun. I started it.
我说，鸟儿们需要那个。鸟车里到处都是田园酱。转向柱几乎没法转动。蜂蜜芥末酱粘糊糊的。然后她说，确实。蜂蜜芥末最糟糕，因为它招果蝇。我说，是的，换挡杆全是甜酸味。而且，田园酱里有乳制品。简直是噩梦。所以那是一场完全正常的鸟类对话。完全有趣。完全好玩。我发起的。
And Maddy's met Eva partway too. She even apologized for filling the house with so much Birdliness, especially when she learned-- through this story, amazingly-- that Eva actively stole and hid Birdly way back when. I had planned to ask Maddy about that thing Eva said earlier, about the birds being quote, unquote, "real." It was on my list of questions. But before I even got to it, she actually brought it up first, told me she had been worried I was going to propose the "are they real" question.
玛迪也和伊娃各让了一步。她甚至为家里充斥着这么多鸟儿气息表示歉意，特别是当她了解到——通过这个故事，令人惊讶地——伊娃很久以前就主动偷走并藏起了鸟鸟。我本打算问玛迪关于伊娃之前说的关于鸟儿们是所谓的“真的”的那件事。它在我的问题清单上。但在我还没提到之前，她实际上先提出来了，告诉我她一直担心我会提出那个“它们是真的吗”的问题。
You know, here I am, it's amazing that I'm a defense lawyer, and then I'm asking myself the question I didn't want to be asked. But I mean, I'm putting it out there. But I can't say that they aren't real to me. I can't shift off of that. I won't shift off of that.
你知道，我在这里，我是一名辩护律师真是不可思议，然后我正在问自己不想被问到的那个问题。但我的意思是，我把它抛出来了。但我不能说它们对我来说不是真的。我不能背离这一点。我不会背离这一点。
Because what would happen if you did?
因为如果你那样做了会发生什么？
I mean-- OK. What would happen? I think we'd be a huge loss. I think it would be a huge loss.
我的意思是——好吧。会发生什么？我想我们会是一个巨大的损失。我想那会是一个巨大的损失。
The kind of loss you might feel when you have to stop playing your favorite sport because your body can't hack it anymore. Or maybe the loss you feel when you finish watching all five seasons of your favorite show, except way, way more so, because this is their show. They created it, and constantly update it, and it's been going on since their real children were in middle school. It gives them some of that feeling of being parents, I think, except without any of the worries, and without having to watch the birds get any older, or fly away.
那种当你不得不停止从事你最喜欢的运动，因为你的身体不再能承受时你可能感受到的损失。或者也许当你看完你最喜欢节目的所有五季时感受到的损失，除了更甚，因为这是它们的节目。它们创作了它，并不断更新它，从他们的亲生孩子在读中学时就开始了。它给了他们一些身为父母的感觉，我想，除了没有任何担忧，也不必看着鸟儿们长大或飞走。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - ROBYN HITCHCOCK, "WE'RE GONNA LIVE IN THE TREES"]
[音乐 - 罗宾·希区柯克，“我们要住在树上”]
Our program is produced today by the man you just heard, Sean Cole. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Jaffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Mary Marge Locker, Tobin Low, Lini Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Chloee Weiner. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由你们刚才听到的那个人，肖恩·科尔制作。制作今天节目的人包括比姆·阿德武米、埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、阿维娃·德科恩费尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、查纳·贾菲-沃尔特（Chana Jaffe-Walt）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、玛丽·玛吉·洛克（Mary Marge Locker）、托宾·洛（Tobin Low）、里尼·米西齐斯（Lini Misitzis）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和克洛伊·温纳。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Special thanks today to Kris Cole, Jennifer Bogo, Katharina Eggman, Emma Young, and Anny Chelsea. In Act 1 of our show, Carmen Melita misspoke. She has been married for 55 years, not 56. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive, over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos, there's lists of favorite shows, tons of other stuff there too. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
今天特别感谢克里斯·科尔（Kris Cole）、詹妮弗·博戈（Jennifer Bogo）、卡塔琳娜·埃格曼（Katharina Eggman）、艾玛·扬（Emma Young）和安妮·切尔西（Anny Chelsea）。在我们节目的第一幕中，卡门·梅利塔说错了。她结婚已经55年了，不是56年。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的存档，超过750集。还有视频，最爱节目列表，那里还有很多其他东西。再说一遍，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's actually sitting right here. Hey, Torey, could you look at your watch and tell me, how much time do we have left in today's show?
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心交付给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia），他就坐在旁边。嘿，托里，你能看下你的手表告诉我有多少时间留给今天的节目了吗？
Just a minute.
等一下。
Thanks, buddy. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
谢谢，老伙计。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - ROBYN HITCHCOCK, "WE'RE GONNA LIVE IN THE TREES"]
[音乐 - 罗宾·希区柯克，“我们要住在树上”]